welcome to 3abn today Bible Q and A my
name is Angela Loma Kang I'm so glad
that you have tuned in today thank you
for joining us each week and thank you
for your prayers and support of this
worldwide Ministry you know we always
have been known as people of the book
the word of God as Seventh-Day
Adventists through the years and today
we are going to be answering your
questions from the word of God well if
you have a question and you'd like to
email us you can email us by going to
Bible qa3abn.tv
and you can text us your questions by
going to
618-228-3975 or you can Instagram Us by
3abn underscore official and that's how
you can reach us
well we have three distinguished panel
here that is sitting right here and I'm
so glad that they are here to answer
your questions and to my right is Jason
Bradley welcome Jason thank you it's
great to be here looking forward to
diving into God's word and answering
these questions amen what do you like
about Bible q a it gives me another
reason to study God's word and to learn
so some of these questions that come in
I may not know the answers to so I have
to search through God's word and find
the answers and I get excited about it
because I'm learning and then I get to
share what I've learned so it's exciting
that's right and next to you is Daniel
Perrin welcome Daniel yes thank you I'm
glad to be here and you work in 3abn
pastoral Department that is true and you
have a wonderful family you have five
beautiful children and recently your
daughter did an amazing sermon at our
church and I was so blessed so welcome
again
how about you the man right in front of
me the man in front of me is my husband
the love of my life yes welcome I'm glad
to hear that every day glad to be on
this program and as you know I've been
studying the Bible for years but some of
our people that send in the questions
you know they have a way of pulling out
a question that I didn't even consider
and like Jason said and I know Daniel is
agreeing on this you always send us back
to a source that is never without light
that's God's word that's right amen well
today we have uh questions and each
question will be answered within three
minutes except one that will be answered
in four minutes and so the before we go
on I'm going to ask for prayer So Daniel
would you open with prayer for us please
I'd love to
dear father in Heaven Lord we come to
you acknowledging that you are the one
who by Your Word created the heavens and
the Earth and by Your Word you are the
one who establishes your character in
our lives and it's your word that we
come to right now asking that you mold
us and change us and help not just to
give us answers but to lead us to the
way the truth and the life that's our
prayer today in Jesus name amen amen
amen we pray that these answers will
draw you closer to the lord well today
we're going to start with Jason Bradley
Jason let's start with this question
since you're a married man now yes
finally I made it
okay the question is is it acceptable to
remarry after a divorce
and the should I break it down in length
or do you want to just yeah you can
break it down okay in length Okay I am
divorced due to relationship issues and
on faithfulness from my ex-spouse it has
been about three years and I have not
entered into a new relationship although
I would like to find a new spouse I do
not want to live in sin is it acceptable
to marry someone new after a divorce
without being considered an adulterer as
re as referenced in Matthew 19 9 this is
Trina from Washington thank you
Trina I'm so sorry to hear that your
marriage didn't work out it's clear from
your question though that you are
interested in doing what is right in the
sight of the Lord and that is so so
important I know you referenced Matthew
Chapter 19 Verse 9 but I think we need
to go back to verse 3 to gain context
now when you think about the Pharisees
here we have the Pharisees and Jesus
having this conversation the Pharisees
were always trying to trap Jesus
um you know and get them put them in a
box and all these types of things they
were trying to trip him up constantly
and I would think of the Pharisees as
like the biggest haters in the world so
let's look at verse three here and then
we'll go on down the Pharisees also came
to him testing him and saying to him is
it lawful for a man to divorce his wife
for just any reason and he answered and
said to them have you not read that he
who made them at the beginning made them
male and female and said for this reason
a man shall leave his father and mother
and be joined to his wife and the two
shall become one flesh so then they are
no longer two but one flesh therefore
what God has joined together let no man
separate they said to him why then did
Moses command to give a certificate of
divorce and to put her away he said to
them Moses because of the hardness of
your hearts permitted you to divorce
your wives but from the beginning it was
not so and I say to you whoever divorces
his wife except for
except for sexual immorality and marries
another commits adultery and whoever
marries her who is divorced commits
adultery
so in answer to your question due to
your husband's unfaithfulness your
marriage biblically qualified for
divorce now we know that God doesn't
want to see marriages dissolve he wants
to see marriages work out but your
marriage biblically qualified for
divorce with that being said if you
decide to remarry you won't be
committing adultery nor will the person
that marries you they won't be
committing adultery either and so I hope
and pray that the man that God sends to
you will be a blessing to you that your
marriage will be happy and fruitful may
God bless you as you use that
discernment and and finding your next
husband yeah amen that's a good very
good answer and a good question that you
sent in and even though somebody has
committed adultery if you can work it
out and they ask for forgiveness then
yeah they it it's okay in God's sight
too you ask for the Lord forgive me for
what I've done and you work hard on that
marriage then yes but yeah the Bible did
say that's the reason okay thank you all
right Daniel here we go
in First Corinthians 10 verse 8 says 23
000 fell in one day but numbers 25 verse
9 tells us that 24
000 fell is there a discrepancy between
the two this is from Lenox in Canada
okay that's a good honest question and
let's address it here by reading both of
those texts First Corinthians chapter 10
verse 8 and Paul's dealing with the
issue of idolatry among God's people he
says nor let us commit sexual immorality
as some of them did and in one day 23
000 fell all right everything we need to
know in that text is right there in one
day 23 000 Phil and he's referring to
the issue at bail por on the banks of
the Jordan River as God's people are
about to possess the promised land there
was idolatry that sprung up in the in in
the people of Israel let's read about it
numbers 25 verses 1 to 9 I'm going to
read the first five verse and then skip
to verse 8. now Israel remained in
Acacia Grove and the people began to
commit harlotry with the women of Moab
they invited the people to the
sacrifices of their gods and the people
ate and bowed down to their gods so
Israel was joined to Baal of peor and
the anger of the Lord was aroused
against Israel then the Lord said to
Moses take all the leaders of the people
and hang the offenders before the Lord
out in the sun at the fierce anger of
the Lord may turn away from Israel so
Moses said to the judges of Israel every
one of you kill his men who were joined
to bail of pior now skipping down to
verse 8 and we have this first mention
of a plague so the plague was stopped
among the children of Israel and those
who died in the plague were 24
000. how can we harmonize these numbers
that are close but different and the
question then is raised how do we answer
any of the questions we have about the
Bible when they appear to be
contradictory and I want to walk you
through my process here because I
personally don't have any wisdom of my
own all that I know I receive all right
from God so I do four things number one
John 16 13 says that the spirit will
lead you into all truth so I ask God
help me Lord to understand this text in
every text that I read and the Holy
Spirit leads me to understand the main
point about idolatry in these texts
number two I read the text again several
times over and over asking Lord is there
anything that I need to understand about
this I look up words in a online
Strong's Concordance to see if there's
any definitions that can help me to
understand them in this case the words
maybe Fel or thousand or plague
and then I'm willing to read
commentaries biblical examples of
students doing this I know Jesus
explained the scriptures to the men
going to Emmaus Philip explain the
scriptures uh in Nehemiah chapter 8 the
Levites explain the meaning of the
scriptures and so when I read some Bible
commentaries I know the Seventh-day
Adventist seven volume Bible commentary
actually addressed this issue all right
and then finally I trust in God by faith
because God has proven himself faithful
and if I don't understand the word of
God it's not because he has made a
mistake but I have so looking at the
text here some people claim that maybe
Paul had a lapse of memory or that he
confused this number with a 23 000 male
Levites that were numbered in numbers 26
but I think the answer can be found in
the phrase 23 000 fell in one day
which means that there was something
happening on multiple days and we know
in that text there was action by the
judges and by the other leaders of
Israel but Paul here is focusing us on
the Divine action the Divine response
and I believe that we can certainly
trust in God's word and the warning is
clear obey God do not put anything in
his place and when you have questions
follow that process ask the Lord and
then allow him to lead you through it
amen that's right well said and when it
says that many fail it's that many died
right in one day that's a lot of people
thank you all right John lomachang
Pastor John can you explain the Rapture
yes you know the word rapture I'm going
to just dive right into it thank you for
the question the word rapture is often
associated with the secret removal of
Christians from the earth you know
somebody driving a bus in the bus driver
disappears somebody's flying a plane the
pilot disappears I am so glad that
that's not true and supported by
scripture because what a pickle people
will be in and if all of a sudden honey
passed me the and your wife just
disappears in front of you this whole I
this whole ideology came about in
something called dispensationalism I
would shorten that by saying
sensationalism because it's not
supported by scripture and even National
Geographics did a a whole program on
this expose how this teaching grew out
of the Dark Ages at a time when people
did not understand the scriptures and
they were taught something that is not
supported by scripture taking Daniel 9
the last seven years that referred to
Christ and pushing that way down in the
future and applying it to the Antichrist
and building around is something called
The Rapture Theory or the Gap Theory
saying when the when when the people
disappear the Jews make a
uh an alliance with the false powers of
Earth and they are converted and they
and they evangelize the world the last
three and a half years all not founded
on scripture at all but the Bible
supports the visible literal second
coming of Jesus here are the number of
scriptures that I give you first of all
the return of Jesus will be visible
Revelation 1 7 behold he is coming with
clouds and every eye will see him even
those who pierced him meaning those who
were instrumental in crucifying Jesus he
made a contract with them are you the
Christ he said I am and you'll see me
come in the Clouds Of Heaven with power
and great Glory so even those who
crucified him will see him return the
visibility of it is also Matthew 24 30.
then the sign of the son of man will
appear in heaven and then all the tribes
of the earth will mourn and they will
see the son of man coming on the Clouds
Of Heaven with power and great Glory
notice all the tribes of the earth so
the coming of the Lord is not just
visible to the Christian but everybody
on Earth that's why Revelation chapter 6
talks about those who are not ready
they'll be running to the rocks in the
mountains saying hide us from the face
of him who sits on the throne and from
the Wrath of the Lamb the Bible goes on
Matthew 24 27 for as the lightning comes
from the East and flashes to the West so
also will the coming of the son of man
be very very visible now let's go down
to the audible aspect of it it's not
only going to be seen but it's going to
be heard Psalm 50 and verse 3 Our God
shall come and shall not keep silent a
fire shall devour before him and it
shall be very tempestuous all around him
so why would the Lord come back silently
who is he hiding from the most glorious
event the Super Bowl is not quiet the
best NBA championship is not quite the
hockey Stanley Cup is not quiet every
the Olympic games are not quite the
event of the ages God is Not tiptoeing
back he is saying you've been praying
for me to come children I'm on my way
what a rejoicing and that's why they're
going to look up and say hello this is
our God we have waited for him it's not
only going to be that
but it's going to affect the entire
Earth and when I talk about the fact
that it's going to be audible let me
give you one more first Thessalonians 4
verse 16 for the Lord himself will
descend from heaven with a shout with
the voice of an archangel with the
trumpet of God many Raptors use that
passage but they use it in vain because
he cannot possibly be silent with a
shout with the voice of the Archangel
with the trumpet of God that trumpet
call is going to be calling the dead
from their graves can you imagine seeing
the graves opening up all around you
Saints coming out of that clothed in
immortality that's not going to be
secret and finally I refer to it it's
going to affect the entire world
Revelation 6 14 to 17 and the sky
reseeded as a scroll when it is rolled
up and every mountain and Island was
moved out of its place it's going to be
a great event
isn't it wow you explained it so well
that will not be secret no it cannot be
and the secret Rapture came by two
people didn't it that's right Francis
Francisco Rivera and Luis di Alcazar one
preterist and one futurist were they
Jesuits they were Jesuits of the Roman
order and they tried to take the
people's eyes away from Rome yes but
they had no Bible support wow
anyway if you have questions you can
send your questions in you can email
your questions in by going to Bible QA
3abn.tv or you can text your questions
in by going to
618-228-3975 or you can Instagram your
questions at 3abn underscore official
okay this is I'm loving this you guys
are great I'm loving this this these
questions and the answers the Lord has
given you from the word of God Jason
okay this is from John in Indiana
years ago after being baptized as an
Adventist I drifted away from God
I am now making my way back to him
praise God and I'm wondering is there
such a thing as getting re-baptized
great question yes John just like you
when I was younger I got baptized and
then I too drifted away from the Lord
and I went astray for many many years
and when I came back to him I made the
decision to rededicate my life to Christ
and and make that public declaration so
I decided to get re-baptized
when we walk away from the Lord
essentially what we're doing is we are
committing spiritual adultery so I want
us to take a look at some scriptures to
gain a better understanding of what
baptism is all about and what it
represents we'll begin in Romans chapter
6 verse 1. what shall we say then shall
we continue in sin that Grace May abound
certainly not how shall we who died to
sin live any longer in it or do you not
know that as many of us as were baptized
into Christ Jesus were baptized into his
death therefore we were buried with him
through baptism into death that just as
Christ was raised from the dead by the
glory of the father even so we also
should walk in what newness of life amen
for if we have been United together in
the likeness of his death certainly we
shall be in the likeness of his
resurrection knowing this that our old
man was crucified with him that the body
of sin might be done away with that we
should no longer be slaves of sin for he
who has died has been freed from sin
verse 9 knowing that Christ having been
raised from the dead dies no more death
no longer has dominion over him what a
blessing verse 11. likewise you also
reckon yourselves to be dead indeed to
sin but alive to God in Christ Jesus our
lord therefore do not let sin reign in
your mortal body that you should obey it
in its lust and then when we look at
Second Corinthians chapter 5 verse 17 we
see something new taking place let's
check that out therefore if anyone is in
Christ he is a what a new creation old
things have passed away behold all
things have become new when we get
baptized we're making a public
Declaration of our faith that we want to
die to self and live for Christ
it's also important to note that just
because we get baptized it doesn't mean
that we won't stumble it doesn't mean
that we won't make mistakes the
important thing is that we get back up
and we keep pressing forward we repent
for our sins and we turn away from them
and turn toward the lord and each time
if you if you make a mistake claim first
John chapter 1 verse 9 if we confess our
sins he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness and so claim that and
turn away from that and turn towards the
Lord but yes nothing is wrong with
getting re-baptized amen I love that
answer that's right and it's from the
word of God right yeah and there's a
song who used to sing We Fall Down but
yeah get up yeah so if you do fall if
it's okay get back up don't go back go
forward all right thank you for that
Jason Daniel
this is an interesting question many
people believe in guardian angels but is
there any proof in scripture to support
this this is from Lynn in New Zealand
All Right Lynn the Bible gives us no
doubt that there are angels but do they
guard us and do they protected us to
protect us I'll give you a few examples
Angels an angel protected Hagar and
Ishmael in Genesis 21 protected a lot in
Genesis 19 an angel guarded Jacob in EX
in Genesis 32 verse 1. Angel attended
Elijah in First Kings 19 of course
Daniel chapter 6 of Daniel an angel
protected him shutting lion's mouth Paul
was guarded by an Angel listen to this
in Acts 27 verse 22 and 23. he uh he
tells the people on the boat that he's
on that there will be no loss of life
because verse 23 there stood by me this
night an angel of the of the god to whom
I belong whom I serve saying do not be
afraid there's an angel right there with
him listen to the Assurance from Psalm
91 which I know many of you have
memorized as children right verse 10
says no evil shall befall you nor shall
any plague come near your dwelling for
he shall give his What Angels charge
over you to keep you in all your ways
and in their hands they shall bear you
up lest you dash your foot against a
stone so here you have angels with the
the mission and purpose of Guardianship
and protection now you can welcome
angels and you can also repel them or
reject them Hebrews chapter 1 Paul is
comparing Jesus ministry to that of
angels and he is superior and he says
here in verse 14 are they not all these
are angels ministering Spirits sent
forth to minister for those who will
inherit salvation so God sends his
angels to you to minister unto you in
other words this ministry is not just
physical protection but this is
spiritual the angels are engaged in a
task of spiritual defense and they are
warriors when Jesus was born the Angels
show up there to the Shepherds and it
says suddenly Luke 2 verse 13. uh there
was with the angel a multitude of the
heavenly host that word host it means
Army it means Warriors and so we see
protection guardianship power and
strength with these angels but you would
not always know it you wouldn't see your
angel Hebrews 13 verse 2 do not forget
to entertain strangers for by so doing
some have unwittingly entertained angels
so you would not recognize it but did
you realize that angels are all around
you now let's get to this text here or
where Jesus says in Matthew 18 verse 10
take heed that you do not despise one of
these little ones which may be children
but it may also be any follower of
Christ for I say to you that their
angels always see the face of my father
who is in heaven they're Angels now
nowhere in the Bible does it say there's
only one or that they do not get
reassigned they outlive you you know or
that they do not take shifts Jesus says
to Nathanael in John 1 51 that you will
see the Angels ascending and descending
on the son of man but the truth is we
have angels with us to guard us and
protect us but they do not force us to
do anything all right the angel in
revelation 22 verse 9 says don't worship
me I am your fellow servant the fact
that God gives us Angels turns our
attention back to him to worship Him
beautiful well said and I love that text
in Hebrews was it 13 2 about we do it as
we have entertained trans angels unaware
and I just interviewed someone yesterday
for 3abn radio and they said the same
thing how they had the man was sick and
he was in the hospital and they was five
people there and the and after he left
the the pastor and the elders left and
the
sick man says wasn't there
wasn't there two other people and they
said wait a minute three of us came
there but who were the two they said
there was no other two these are extra
tall men and with white hair and they I
they said they believe it was Angels
thank you for that wow all right Pastor
John this is a four minute question
should we be baptized in the name of the
father Son and Holy Ghost no one in the
Bible is baptized that way see Acts 2 38
and Acts 19 5 is not the name Jesus
above every name this is a viewer in
Ghana yes thank you for the question but
let me remind you and this is something
that I've noticed through the years of
ministry because of misunderstanding
they tend to pit Peter against Christ
Paul against Christ the Jews against
Christ when it comes to the Sabbath it's
amazing how the words of Christ have
lost Authority in the Christian World in
other words they're saying here well
Peter was right but Jesus was wrong and
Peter was only fulfilling the commission
that Jesus gave him the authority to
fulfill so the question is why would
Peter say that when Jesus said prior to
Peter saying what he did in Acts why
would Peter say be baptized in the name
of Jesus when Jesus said in the name of
the father Son and the Holy Spirit let
me help you understand the context of it
up until that point the New Testament
Church was just being established the
name of Jesus was new in the Earth even
the Holy Spirit wasn't even understood
because the Holy Spirit was poured out
on the day of Pentecost on the apostles
they thought that they already had the
power the Lord said no way to Jerusalem
and then you'll receive the power
so you find the one element that was
consistent all throughout was God he was
never misunderstood all throughout the
Old Testament but you find John 14 verse
1 to 3 and this is why Jesus said to his
disciples these words
you believe in God
believe also in me why because the Bible
says in Acts 4 and verse 12 neither is
there salvation in any other for there
is no other name unto Heaven given among
men whereby we must be saved what name
the name of Jesus why John 1 29 Behold
the Lamb of God that take away the sin
of the world the father and the son were
United in this in this venture to Free
Man from sin so
Jesus was not doing something that he
would have to convince his father as
good or convince the holy spirit that
well this is what you should have done
in the first place no this was the
United Venture of salvation but the name
of Jesus was unknown remember this Jesus
only had a three and a half year
Ministry prior to that nobody hardly
knew who he was they misunderstood his
origin aren't you the guy from aren't
you The Carpenter's son the Jew said how
could you be older than our Father
Abraham how old are you right and he
said before Abraham was I am so he was
trying to establish his identity the
power of the New Testament Church was in
introducing Jesus the savior of the
world yes so they already knew God as a
matter of fact you find here in Acts
chapter 238 what Peter talked about on
the day of Pentecost repent and be
baptized in the name of Jesus for the
remission of sin why because it's the
blood of Jesus that takes away our
putrefying sins it is the method whereby
our sins are washed away you can't be
saved if that's the case then the Jews
don't need you Jesus to be saved but
they're not saved because they've
rejected Jesus and I'm going to be very
respectful there are other religions
that accept only God alone but Jesus
says you believe in God believe also in
me because there's no other name the
unity of the godhead was being
commissioned here by Christ that's why
he says
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit so Acts chapter 19 was a
reiteration of this let's look at Acts
19 and you know the other parts but I'm
going to start with verse 2 because G
Paul is now speaking to those in Corinth
and he is saying in verse 2 and he said
to them did you receive the Holy Spirit
when you believed watch this they hadn't
even heard of the Holy Spirit
and he said to them uh they said we have
not so much has even heard whether there
is a holy spirit so he was also
introducing the Holy Spirit was the Holy
Spirit invalid to that point no he was
being introduced because they did not
understand anything other than what they
had previously known then he said in
verse 4 then Paul said
in verse 4 so they said into anything in
verse 4 into what then were you were
baptized and they said into John's
baptism he was the authority to that
point right then Paul said John indeed
baptized with the baptism of repentance
but then he goes on and he says but he
said to the people that they should
believe
on him who would come after him that is
on Christ Jesus and when they heard this
they were baptized in the name of the
Lord Jesus now what's the answer here
yes the name of if you follow the word
there in the Greek the authority of is
there an authority that Jesus has that
the father doesn't have and the Holy
Spirit doesn't have no no that's why
Jesus United them in the commission go
therefore this Authority is one in
the godhead that's all that was being
done by Peter he was introducing to them
someone that had not previously known
like the Holy Spirit and Jesus Christ
through whom we have salvation amen they
didn't understand and understand it yeah
yeah thank you wonderful you made that
very clear now if you have just joined
in and you have questions that you would
like to send in you can email us by
going to Bible QA at
3abn.tv or you can text us by going to
618-228-3975 and you can go to Instagram
if you go to Instagram quite often is it
at 3abn underscore official okay all
right thank you so much that was a great
answer
Jason
this is uh okay this is an interesting
question this is from Maria in
California
when we are born God gives us a soul and
we are all children of God our Father is
this correct
um
Maria let me start by addressing the
first part of your question where you uh
mentioned you thought when we are born
God gives us a soul I want you to
Journey with me to Genesis chapter 2
verse 7 and we'll we'll look at the King
James version because this version
actually uses the word soul in this text
and the Lord God formed man of the Dust
of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and Man
became a living Soul now notice that it
didn't say God gave man a living Soul
Man became a living soul for the other
part of your question are we not all
children of God the short answer is no
we're not all children of God we were
all created by God but there is a
difference between being his creation
and and being his children there's a big
difference there first John chapter 3
verses 1 through 3. behold what manner
of love the father has bestowed on us
that we should be called children of God
therefore the world does not know us
because it did not know him so notice
that right there the world does not know
us the world does not know children of
God because it did not know him behold
now we are children of God and it has
not yet been revealed what we shall be
but we know that when he is revealed we
shall be like him for we shall see him
as he is and everyone who has this hope
in him purifies himself just as he is
pure now jumping down to verse 7 and 8
we see little children let no one
deceive you he who practices
righteousness is righteous just as he is
righteous he who sins is of the devil
so if you're of the devil you can't be a
child of God for the devil has sinned
from the beginning for this purpose the
Son of God was manifested that he might
destroy the works of the devil John
chapter 8 verses 44 and 47. you are of
your father the devil and the desires of
your father you want to do he was a
murderer from the beginning and does not
stand in the truth because there is no
truth in him when he speaks a lie he
speaks from his own resources for he is
a liar and the father of it he who is of
God hears God's words so that that right
there he who is of God that signifies
that there are people that aren't of God
right so he who is of God hears God's
words therefore you do not hear because
you are not of God
for further clarification children of
God will do the works of God and by
their fruits you shall know them people
of the world are like an emancipated
minors that don't want to be a part of
the family and we all should want to be
a part of God's family well said Thank
exactly we all should be but
unfortunately there are some that choose
not to yes yeah but Lord is not willing
that any should perish thank you for
that Jason
okay Daniel this is an interesting
question
and so many people have asked this
throughout the years I've always heard
this in Ministry
there is only one God
why are there so many religions this is
from Sandra North Dakota
all right and I know a variety of people
could answer this in in great ways and I
I've heard other people answer this and
this is a good question one God and that
one God has one unified system of truth
that reflects him one truth now you can
Shine the Light on the truth from every
different angle but it's still one truth
that goes like this John 14 verse 6
Jesus said to him I am the way the truth
and the life no one comes to the father
except through me this is the exclusive
claim of Christ it's not the claim of
Christianity it is the claim of Christ
first John 5 12 he who has the son has
life right you've got to have the son he
who does not have the son does not have
life there's one truth now you can lie
about the truth in as many ways as you
can imagine or make up to do it if you
were the enemy of Truth what would you
do set up just one one competitor so
they could be easily compared to see
which one is true and which one is false
now you'd flood the market with a host
of look-alikes with a host of knocks
knockoffs so that way it doesn't matter
which version of the lie you choose all
right any one of them is going to be as
much a lie as the other and so there's
only one truth and so the enemy tries to
flood the market flood the world a
Marketplace of Faith people call it so
that they all look similar all look
about the same all right and this is the
enemies of the enemy's strategy let's
make each of these other lies look moral
almost every other religion agrees that
you should not kill well look they're
all similar they all say don't kill they
must all be the same thing and so pick
your truth It All Leads up the mountain
they say and this is the enemy strategy
my brother lives 2 000 miles away from
me he calls me one day and says hey what
are you doing I'm driving me too he says
what do you see well there's a black
thing stretching out in front of me and
a yellow line on this side and a white
line on this side that's what I see we
must be on the same road and so this is
the enemy's strategy to introduce as
many different ideas that then keep you
from recognizing the truth and what it
is religions develop in a place and so
they develop out of people think about
Hinduism the worship of rivers and
nature and this so-called God within you
and selfish pleasure to the denying of
the fact that there is even a physical
world all there is is a spiritual a
spiritual World well out of that comes a
guide who is called people call him the
Buddha and he rejected all that and he
established his own version of it saying
all that exists is the physical world
and there is no spiritual world at all
and so this is the enemy's tactic to
have people introduce as many new ideas
different ideas as possible to keep you
from God all right error is spread by
people motivated by by the enemy and the
same is true of the truth which is Jesus
it is spread by people motivated by the
Holy Spirit and that person is you thank
you for that in Matthew 7 13-14 narrow
is the way and it leads onto eternal
life and few there be that find it
wonderful thank you okay pastor John
this is an interesting question due to
my age and health issue I am no longer I
no longer participate in foot Washing
Service however I do participate in the
rest of communion service is my partaken
in communion unworthy Catherine from New
Mexico this is a very quick answer thank
you Kathy for that question
there are a few people and but I'm sure
there are more than I know
that have had the same issue some people
have issues with their feet some people
are shy some people have literally foot
diseases that they don't want publicly
it's not in it's not an indication of
their heart towards God the ordinance of
humility is what the foot Washing
Service is called it's an act of
willingness to be humbled to serve one
another and Jesus said in John 13 he
left that he left it as an example that
we should do as he has done but now you
have to ask yourself the question what
about somebody who's an amputee can they
not take communion service what about
people who literally have a cast on
their feet should they not come to
communion until the cast is removed no
the condition of the heart is more
important than what happens to the foot
some people wash their feet but they
don't change their hearts so we have to
understand the context here the Lord
understands and when you look at the
real application for the communion
service it's in First Corinthians 11
verse 26 for as often as you eat this
bread and drink this cup you proclaim
the Lord's death till he comes as long
as we accept the broken body and shed
blood of Jesus then his righteousness is
efficacious to us people could wash
their feet wash their hands as pilate
did but still be guilty because their
hearts are not changed
wow
well thank you for that amen that's your
time yeah give us a little more time I
like that okay Jason
this is going to be your four minute
question yes yeah and it's an
interesting one I was oh it's all of
them are so thank you for sending your
questions in
it says here I have been trying to be a
better Christian and not sin
but I know that I do sin and have sinned
willfully and struggled daily not to sin
my question concerns Hebrews 10 verse 26
and Hebrews 10 verse 38.
am I then fruitless in my Redemption
because of an active choice I made
I might be on the Lord's Mercy
this is Barrel an email from barrel all
right barrel uh well let's take a look
at Hebrews chapter 10 verses 26 and 38
since you referenced those for if we sin
willfully after we have received the
knowledge of the truth there no longer
remains a sacrifice for sins now the
just shall live by faith but if anyone
draws back my soul has no pleasure in
him
people will not be lost because they
sinned they will be lost because they
did not repent that's right Romans
chapter 3 verse 23 says for all have
sinned and fall short of the glory of
God God has given us the responsibility
to help people with restoration
Galatians chapter 6 verse 1. it says
Brethren if a man is overtaken in any
trespass you who are spiritual restore
such a one in a spirit of gentleness
considering yourself lest you also be
tempted please know that as I share this
message with you it is coming from a
place of humility it's not a place of
condemnation or anything like that we
all struggle but by willfully sinning
you place yourself in a very dangerous
position and perhaps you've heard the
tale of the two frogs right these two
frogs were in in a pot it was the water
was warm to start and they they're
sitting in this pot in this warm water
and as the heat gradually intensifies it
gradually gets hotter and hotter they're
just having the time of their little
lives because they're thinking they're
in the jacuzzi right so until they end
up cooked why did I tell you or why did
I share this illustration with you it's
because that's how sin is you see we
start off gradually with sin and then it
it intensifies it gets worse and it's a
downward spiral we continue to spiral
downward until we end up getting hooked
and cooked and I don't know about you
but I don't want to be cooked so when we
willfully sin we operate under the
assumption that we'll have time to get
our life together and we know that
tomorrow isn't promised Second
Corinthians chapter 6 verses 1 and 2 we
then as workers together with him also
plead with you not to receive the grace
of God in vain for he says in an
acceptable time I have heard you and in
the day of salvation I have helped you
behold now is the accepted time behold
now is the day of salvation the fact
that you're watching this program and
you ask this question shows that the
holy spirit is working on you to convict
you of your wrongdoing and that is a
great sign you are not beyond the Lord's
Mercy but it's time for you to repent
resist the devil and turn towards the
Lord I leave you with this word of
encouragement it's from Philippians
chapter 3 verses 13 and 14. Brethren I
do not count myself to have apprehended
but one thing I do forgetting those
things which are behind and reaching
forward to those things which are ahead
I press toward the goal for the prize of
the upward call of God in Christ Jesus
continue to to press for it continue to
reach out to the Lord
supersaturate your life with Christ
listen to Christian music spend time
with Christian people that will keep you
in the word stay in God's word and
remember iron sharpens iron spend time
with God let go of those things of the
world and I believe that you will see a
great difference
amen and no they're not beyond the
Lord's Mercy amen yeah Lord's mercies
are new every day great is your
faithfulness thank you for that okay
let's go Daniel here we go you got the
four minute question
oh this is interesting again who are the
sons of God mentioned in Genesis 6. this
is from Marcus in Minnesota okay now
I've heard this question from time to
time and I'm thankful that the Bible
does give us a clear answer let's just
look at that phrase where we see it
elsewhere John chapter 1 verse 12 says
but as many as received him that's Jesus
to them gave he the power to become the
sons of God okay Romans 8 verse 14 says
for as many as are led by the spirit of
God they are the sons of God together
these texts along with others are
painting the picture that these are
God's people Matthew 5 verse 9 blessed
are the peacemakers for they shall be
called the sons of God and some
translations render this as the children
of God so these are those people who
choose faithfulness and obedience to God
now let's put that into the context of
what we see in Genesis chapter 6 verse 1
and 2 says now it came to pass when men
began to multiply on the face of the
earth and the daughters were born to
them at the sons of God saw the
daughters of men that they were
beautiful and they took wives for
themselves of all whom they chose from
the very start God gave a choice and
there were two ways it was true with
Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden there
are two trees and that same thing was
presented to Cain and Abel their sons
and Seth as well and we see that Cain
chose his own way murdered his brother
Genesis 4 verse 16 and 17 says that then
Cain went out from the presence of the
Lord dwelt in the land of not on the
East of Eden in the next verse and he
built a city all right Genesis 4 then
continues to tell the story of Cain's
descendants departing farther and
farther from God going out from his
presence dwelling in cities on the other
hand by comparison you have the
descendants of Seth there listed in
Genesis chapter 5 telling their story
and they're contrasted with Cain's
descendants they did not depart from the
presence of God they did not dwell in
cities they preserved righteousness from
one generation to the next and so here's
the difference the sons of God are those
who are faithful to God and then the
sons of men have departed from
faithfulness to God now as they began to
multiply on the face of the Earth they
begin to interact and the sons of God
looked out and they said wow I like some
some of the things that are going on
over there and so they began to
intermarry with them and when that
happened God God wants his people to be
distinct Deuteronomy chapter 7 verse 3
God says don't intermary with those who
don't have faith in God and Paul says
the same thing there in second
Corinthians 6 4 not to be unequally
yoked with others
and so as they begin intermarrying their
result is spiritual degeneration and so
that's who the sons of God God are there
those who are faithful to God some
people want to know who are then the
Giants of renown who are mentioned uh
later and well when those when uh two
isolated populations uh when they
finally enter Mary there is a
strengthening of the genetic pool and so
you had strong men wise a strong man who
uh came out of that lesson uh here is
that you have a choice over which family
to belong to all right thank you all
right great answer
okay pastor John this boy this is like a
four minute question answer this is good
when was the devil cast out from heaven
was it before or after the death of
Christ on the cross this is from Justine
in Zambia I've I've found a way to make
it maybe about a one and a half minute
question oh okay the devil was cast out
of Heaven before creation this was and
this is during the process of creation
to be more specific Revelation 12 7-9
and let me just give you the context he
could not have been cast out after the
cross he had to be in the garden in
order to be able to be to be channeling
through the serpent he had to be in the
earth that's why the Lord warned them in
Genesis 2 to watch out for the tree of
the knowledge of Good and Evil for the
day you either of you shall surely die
sin was lurking in the Earth but it had
not found an entrance yet the devil was
waiting for Eve to come to the tree so
we find in Revelation chapter 12 verse
7-9 it talks about the war in heaven
Michael and his angels fought against
the dragon but it says in verse 9 so the
Great Dragon was cast out that Serpent
of all called the devil and Satan he was
cast to the Earth as Angels were cast
out with him that's the means whereby as
First Corinthians or second Corinthians
11 verse 3 says
Paul talks about how Eve was deceived by
the craftiness of the serpent he says
lest some somehow as the serpent
deceived Eve by his craftiness that
happened because he was here in the
Earth but let's took let's look at the
other part that you didn't answer or
that you didn't ask I'm going to get
this part yes
he was cast out
in the beginning he was cast down at the
cross that's why you find Revelation 12
and verse 10 then I heard a loud voice
from Heaven saying now salvation and
strength and the kingdom of our God and
the power of His Christ have come for
the accuser of our Brethren who accused
them before God day and night has been
cast down cast out you're kicked out but
you still have limited access that's why
job said the day came when the sons of
God came to present themselves before
the Lord and Satan came also he was not
afraid of Jesus just because he was
being born he was fearful that he may
lose the authority he had in the Earth
by Adam falling into sin and taking
Dominion from Adam Adam delivered the
Dominion to Satan by his transgression
Jesus came to take it back when he took
it back Satan was cast down and from
then on he knew that his time was short
so here's the answer he was cast out
during creation cast down at the cross
wow I'm glad you mentioned job because
remember Satan came and visited and all
that I'm glad you mentioned that because
I was going to bring that up wow I am
enjoying these Bible answers you guys
are wonderful I am so blessed I hope you
are learning something new I am being
blessed the holy spirit is with us and
he's with you also listener viewer and
so what we're going to do is take a
break and we will be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back I hope you have your
questions answered I know I had some
answered well we're going to have a few
closing thoughts from our panelists
Jason yes I just want to share Romans
chapter 8 verses 38 and 39 for I am
persuaded that neither death nor life
nor angels nor principalities nor powers
nor things present nor things to come
nor height nor depth nor any other
created thing shall be able to separate
us from the love of God which is in
Christ Jesus our lord carry that in your
hearts amen Daniel and I just finished
the question on the sons of God and I
just want to remind you that it's not a
mysterious mystical thing it's something
that God invites you and I to become he
invites us into his family listen to
First John chapter 3 verse 1. behold
what manner of love that's the love that
you spoke about the father has upon us
that we should be called the children of
God God and I just want to extend that
invitation to you today First John 3 1
beautiful and Revelation 12 12 you know
there's a declaration woe to the
inhabitants of the earth and of the sea
for the devil has come down unto you
having great wrath because he knows he
has a short time he is determined to
deceive and one of those grand
deceptions he has packaged so
beautifully and delivered to the
Christian world is this idea that the
church is going to be snatched away
they're going to all disappear they're
not going to be here during the
tribulation well friends that's not
supported by scripture as the Israelites
were in Egypt when the plagues fell
we're going to be in the Earth but the
protecting here is going to be God is
going to protect his people Psalm 91 so
trust God's word and you won't have to
worry about what's ahead of you wow
thank you guys you did a wonderful job I
was blessed and I know you were also and
in closing I want to share this text
with you in John 17 17 sanctify them by
your truth Thy Word is truth
I hope you have a blessed day and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
foreign